this video is brought to you by
manscape.com the global brand for men's
grooming and hygiene products
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's feeling
fang-tastic after just watching the new
mobius trailer so jared let's go through
it frame by frame as we point out all
the easter eggs things you missed and
talk about how it connects to the
greatest spider-man universe there's so
many things going on with it and little
hints towards characters like black cat
the rhino and even norman osborne from
here on out it's full of spoilers ahead
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out then i highly recommend that you
check out now i don't want any bad blood
between us so smash the thumbs up button
and also subscribe if the puns leave you
down for the count like dracula's
loyalist servant without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
mobius
okay so it's clear from the trailers
that mobius is gonna be massively
leaning into its connection to
spider-man and the collective web around
the marvel universe over the last couple
of days there's been some vignettes
dropped international trailers normal
trailers and a lot of things that i want
to combine into one video to discuss the
movie
the first trailer of course had a
picture of sam raimi's spider-man in it
with the words murderer spray painted
over the top and it also featured a
cameo from michael keaton who's
reprising his role as adrian toombs the
brand new international trailer showed
him introducing himself whilst also
saying that the dark should keep in
touch
clearly morbius's reputation is known at
this point and it could be that he's
being taken in by a police officer after
his arrest for murder now venom let
there be carnage ended with eddie brock
being transported into the mcu and
though we don't know what universe this
will take place in there are some really
cool easter eggs and ties to the comics
the international trailer ended with
morbius jokingly saying i'm venom so
it's likely that he's in the one that
we've been in during the venom films it
was said by kevin feige that the
post-credits scene of let there be
carnage was done at the last minute and
as mobius was filmed many moons ago it
could be that they didn't have things
fully set in place when they were making
it they could have not known that there
would be a multiverse and that it would
all be connected but either way it does
seem like morbius is tied into a lot of
things like mobius now i kind of think
that this might even be in its own
universe with connections to other
universes and that he might be pulled
into the mcu much in the same way that
venom was this could be how blade ends
up getting his powers in the mcu as in
the comics mobius bit the hero and this
gave him his supernatural abilities in
loki we also had the mention of vampires
out in the multiverse which in some ways
could have teased this reality let us
know your best theories below but it
would allow for characters like the
vulture to pop up have mobius mention
venom and also keep things like the
daily bugle as a newspaper without
breaking the universe now speaking of
the daily bugle we catch a mobius
looking over the front page of it in the
new teaser the logo and font is similar
to the rhymian venomverse whereas in the
mcu it's an infowars-esque type of new
show so that adds weight to it being
within its own reality it could even be
that strange messed up the spell so
badly in no way home that this cracked
the multiverse open and everyone's been
going back and forth more than the
eternals rotten tomatoes score now the
headline on a reads that mobius has been
arrested for a vampire type murder this
explains why at one point he's wearing a
prison jumpsuit
and it also hints towards the cost of
his powers namely his need for blood
however if we look beyond that and the
headlines at the top you'll also see
some cool little nods to other
spider-man characters the first reads
that a rhino is on the loose and that
this is a zoo hoax might mean that we're
going to be seeing the actual villain or
it could just be a prank but either way
it's a nice little nod to that infamous
spider-man villain next to it reads
black cat friend of foe and this is
clearly giving us our first hints
towards the femme fatale from the comics
black cat or rather felicia hardy is a
jewel thief who's pretty much been a
love interest and antagonist to
spider-man so it's great that they're
referencing her in this and i'd love to
see a solo movie from her down the line
now we also catch glimpses of oz corp
tower which is of course owned by norman
osborne due to the pumpkin bombs in the
norway home trailer we know that willem
dafoe will be reprising his role as the
green goblin however it has been said
that it won't be the one from the reimus
per se and instead it'll be a what if
version from across the multiverse who
knows it might even be this universe and
he could get pulled across with mobius
now what if i told you my wife calls me
wang the conqueror well she doesn't but
she might and that's because for the
last month i've been using manscape's
new all-in-one performance package 4.0
the lawnmower 4.0 is the sleekest
electric trimmer manscaped have ever
released and not only is it waterproof
but it comes with advanced skin safe
technology that provides a shave more
stylized than tony stark's beard it also
has a super smart cordless charging
system that gives you power for 90
minutes and led lights that make it look
like it's powered by the ark reactor on
top of this the pack also has two
products i didn't even know i needed
until now and that is the crop preserver
ball deodorant and crop revivable toner
spray simply apply the crop preserver
after a shower for all day body odor
protection and use the crop reviver on
your infinity stones any time of the day
now i'm going to be honest yeah i've got
a
bit of a big snout so the weed whacker
was completely life-changing it helps to
get the nose hairs right at the back and
it's also got the same skin safe
technology that the lawn mower does so
you don't have to worry about cutting or
tugging on sensitive hairs now for a
limited time only you also get two free
gifts and these include the anti-chafing
boxer briefs and also the amazing travel
bag that puts a suit of armor around
your kit wherever you go go to
manscape.com and get 20 off as well as
free international shipping when you
enter heavy20 at the checkout the link
is in the description below and just
enter heavy20 at the checkout for this
life-changing deal i'm off to go save
some lives i'll see you next time or in
the rest of this video
now for the next part of the video i
kind of want to do a big breakdown of
everything that we know from all the
teasers as there has been quite a lot
shown in the trailers which we can use
to piece together what will be happening
in the movie as we know mobius is going
to be following michael mobius the
living vampire and it'll very much
chronicle his life so far the trailers
have shown the character winning a nobel
prize for his involvement in blood
research but for as many developments as
he was making morbius himself was living
on borrowed time according to the plot
leaks just after michael collects his
nobel prize he collapses on stage and
this is what really drives him to try
and find a cure in the comics this blood
disease is what makes him look like some
thing from the twilight zone but here it
mainly just gives him muscle weaknesses
we know from the trailers that as a
child morbius attended a greek school
and in the comics the character mobius
was actually from greece now at this
school we know that he'll be mentored by
jared harris's character who currently
hasn't been named in any of the cast
list however it is possible that he's
actually emil nicos who pulls directly
from the comics i kind of feel that
harris might end up becoming one of the
villains in the movie as we don't have
his name and they're clearly keeping
that secret for a reason however there
is also matt smith's character which
we'll talk about later on and you can
watch me purposely avoid saying his name
because i have no idea how to pronounce
it now it was said in the plot leaks
before the first trailer was posted that
morbius and nicos will end up playing a
game of chess against one another during
a flashback scene nicolas then leaves
and this would definitely set up their
rivalry which could play into the rest
of the movie saying that though he does
judge him quite harshly and sort of seem
disappointed with him so he could just
genuinely be a nice guy like your uncle
kevin spoilers who people seem to hate
because he ruined avengers end game and
also christmas now with his fiancee
martine bancroft morbius experiments on
himself with vampire bats and in the
comics this is what gave him his
abilities the movie does seem to be
potentially changing things up though as
there's a strange cave out on a
mysterious island that seemingly
requires some sort of blood sacrifice in
order to bring forth the bats that live
there in the trailers we have seen as
mobius has brought forth these creatures
by touching a machine there and that
they all swarmed and killed everyone at
the location other than him now
according to the leaks it's after this
that he sneaks on board a ship in order
to travel home and this is where we get
the vampire-esque hunting scene that's
been played throughout all of the
trailers from here it looks like he's
captured and put inside a lab whilst he
still figures out his powers and also
how to stop his thirst for blood whilst
keeping all of the benefits of his super
strength and teleportation i think that
the way that his powers are but across
is absolutely incredible and he has the
ability to sort of teleport and move at
great speeds this means that he can
pretty much appear and disappear at will
and it's such a cool thing to have a
vampire character doing all of the
action scenes from the trailers
featurettes and so on look great and
it's gonna be brilliant watching him
sort of nightcrawler his way across
locations as he comes to grips with his
brand new abilities now this comes at a
cost and he of course has to drink blood
i think it's going to be really
interesting to see how the movie handles
that as he's going to be someone that
wants to do good but he has to drain
people of their life force in order to
survive i'm really curious to see how
they weigh it all up but i think that it
makes for quite a complicated character
i think that the quote-unquote sony
heroes all sort of being bad guys from
the comics means that they have an edge
to them and the opportunity to discuss
morality which a lot of the marvel ones
simply don't possess now as we see in
the trailers morbius is going to have to
evade the law as well this will come in
the form of simon stroud who will be
played by tyrese gibson in the new looks
we see him holding up a paper bat left
behind at a crime scene but i don't
think this is from mobius and i think
that it's actually going to be put there
by lotious crown locks loxius crown oxy
crown now in the comics stroud dealt a
lot with the supernatural and he also
investigated jay jonah jameson's son
when he became a werewolf i'd love to
see him as a sort of vampire hunter and
in the very first trailer you might have
spotted that he has a bionic arm of some
sort which shows that he might be
upgrading himself throughout the movie
in order to combat this new threat now
lotious crown loxius crown who i'll just
be calling crown from now on is probably
gonna be the big bad overall from the
first looks it seems like he's gonna be
the one who tells mobius about the
mysterious island and we know from
behind the scenes images that he's going
to be a guiding figure for the character
according to plot leaks on the film he
will have had a similar disease to
mobius and he'll show up completely
cured which is when he will tell him
about the rare vampire bats now in the
comics crown would end up going on to
become a villain known as hunger
devourer of realities this was a
parasitic organism that fed on universes
and it is possible that the character
could even destroy this reality which
will force more beerus into another one
i'd love to see that in the film and he
makes way more sense as being a villain
over nikos but you know let your boy
have his fan theories as they've never
steered you wrong
now as for my thoughts on the film i was
pretty much one of those people who
thought that this movie was gonna suck
that's not a vampire pun by the way now
though venom has always been a guilty
pleasure of mine and into the
spider-verse was incredible i was very
much in the mind state that sony just
have no idea what they're doing right
now and it's been a long time since
their golden era with sam raimi's
spider-man however i am really on board
with this and i think it looks like a
very fun movie that sort of leans into
what sony can do best obviously they're
gonna troll kevin feige and put as many
marvel easter eggs in it as they can so
they can pretty much piggyback off the
mcu success but i actually enjoy what
direction sony can go with their
characters and the moral complexities
that they have
there have been a couple of screenings
for the movie and from what i've been
told behind the scenes this is gonna be
a surprisingly good film that sets up
mobius as one of the most unique and
interesting heroes that we've ever seen
in a marvel movie it's meant to be
packed with cool action scenes but
there's also a lot of character
development and things to make you
really gravitate towards morbius leto
was let down by suicide squad but this
is meant to feel very much like a second
chance at a comic book movie for the
actor that he doesn't waste his time
with all of the trailers have done a
great job of getting me hyped for the
movie and i love how they're really
leading into the greater marvel universe
and teasing other films in the film
hopefully we get that rumored black cat
movie announcement soon as i think that
would be another good character to
explore either way though this new look
did a great job of selling a movie that
i wasn't too hyped about and i can't
wait to see it in january i hope you
enjoyed the video and obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the new look in
the comments below as a thank you for
leaving your thoughts you'll be entered
into a competition on the 30th of
november in which we're giving away
three copies of the zack snyder dc
trilogy all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the teaser we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the book of boba fett
trailer which will be linked on screen
right now it's a lot of cool little plot
elements that you can spot in it and
also some great hidden details so i hope
you go check it out right after this if
not then thank you for sticking through
the video i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see you on the next one
take care peace